[Music]
ten years ago we dropped the first viral
video on
corridor we wanted to take a moment here
and create some pieces
that reflect our most iconic moments for
the quarter channel our most iconic
moments of filmmaking
let's jump in
so today we're doing a render challenge
that's going to reflect on the 10
years of videos we've been putting out
on corridor
and well i feel like this wouldn't be a
render challenge
without our great friend clinton jones
so i think i'm going to call him
to have him come back in for one last
render challenge
who it's sam samu
hey clint what's up hey um hey we're
doing this 10-year render challenge and
uh
i i just don't think we could do it
without you um
would you be down yeah absolutely yeah
of course man that sounds like fun
okay i could drive down probably be
there pretty pretty quick
yeah you want to meet at the studio like
like right now yeah sure i'll come down
right now
cool all right peace see ya get the old
shoes on
okay what's up guys hey yeah
yeah so we're gonna do the renders over
here yeah cool ten years ago we dropped
the first viral video on corridor
minecraft the last minecart which has
often
been inaccurately referred to as
minecraft last minecraft
when was the actual release date of the
last minecart february 17th
2011. isn't that that's the day peter
was born too that was
yeah didn't nick shoot that i did we got
to meet notch after making it it was
it was wild we were like wow this is
going somewhere so
we wanted to take a moment here and
reflect on this history that we've done
and where we've come
from and create some pieces that
reflect upon our most iconic moments
for the corridor channel our most iconic
moments of filmmaking and there's five
of us
and we're gonna make five pieces of art
they're each going to be a
character and environment portrait so
the general idea is that we're going to
be looking at a character in a world
around them
and that's going to speak to a video or
an experience or story that stuck with
us
what i'm really excited to see here is
what it looks like when we reapproach it
the minecraft video is 10 years old i
was a baby basically
what i've learned since then if i was to
reapproach that video or that concept
i would i don't know i'm really curious
to see what that would look like dude
i'm deciding between two videos
longest lightsaber but at the same time
portal trick shots is pretty sweet
i want to revisit those stakes because
like that stake shot against the back
wall
it just wasn't enough to snuff so do you
feel the quality of that shot is lacking
up to your
standard missed stakes and that yeah
absolutely dude
tentatively i'm going to say dubstep
guns but or frozen crosstalk
we'll see i don't know there's lots of
thoughts going around up here
boss town robot and his dog standing at
a mountain peak
like a sequel more or less to boss down
dynamics too i would need the blessing
of clint you know sam yeah do it that'd
be sick
i don't know i'm gonna save my judgment
until after i see it
120 frames at 24 frames per second that
gives us five seconds
of footage to make perfect ideally
ideally it loops no
it has to loop oh of course it has to
loop that's our restraint
make it work let's jump in
[Music]
let's just jump let's just jump let's
just jump in
let's just jump on let's just jump in
dude
we've made a lot of projects over the
last 10 years lots and lots of projects
lots of videos
we back up old projects on these hard
drives it's a really janky sword
solution
thankfully there's a handy dandy google
doc for my render i want to do
a piece that has one of the newest photo
scans of me one that was taken last week
for peter's game
and the oldest one i can possibly find
because i think i want the contrast to
be there i want
like slim sam and then dad sam with a
gut you know i want i want to see that
like
i want to see my body change to do that
i got to find the oldest skin
i can think of and the first one that
comes to mind is the one i did for
footloose that was like the very
first time i figured out how to do 3d
scan we were using an xbox kinect
or is that project just too old
sometimes these projects are just like
they just disappear
and no one really knows what happens to
them what other videos
one is the far cry 4 video far cry 4
e all right can i find a driver oh
all right cool oh it's blinking oh
that's very trippy not gonna lie this is
really trippy
that was me when i was freaking
like 27 or 28. i'm almost 35 now
i'm an old freaking fart but wow this
would be really cool
i think i've got a really cool render on
my hands
[Music]
dubstep guns has a very special place in
my heart because i saw
dubstep guns when i was like 12 years
old and i was like this is the coolest
thing i've ever seen
the one shot where mike shoots his laser
and there's the
shock wave and everything i thought that
was so cool i've seen that thousands of
times
and we're going too hard too hard we
went too hard you're breaking my heart
here man
if there's anything i learned from the
beep it's that composition
is everything i decided to go with a
centered composition for this
with sam holding the dubstep gun being
the main subject of the shot and then
kind of in a triangular formation behind
him we got
nico and mike so i decided to take a
look at
portal trick shots not the first but one
of the first videos i directed for
corridor digital
the idea for the shot is i wanted to
have sam nico kind of just in the
foreground
with the pillar behind them with a
portal on it because the iconic shot
from portal trick shots in my opinion is
basically the thumbnail
with the blue portal on the side of the
pillar with nico spinning a basketball
on his finger so i wanted to have that
basically be the main
visual component of this video with the
addition
of an actual basketball falling through
the portals over and over again
that's the idea
[Applause]
the first primtech video has the first
shot i
ever did after picking up c4d again
so these stakes here took me a week the
first time i did this
you can even still see some glitchiness
some bugs in that export
and i figured that i'm going to recreate
the primtech
zombie meat harvester shot so my
inspiration for this was the boss town
dynamics series which i
think is our current most iconic thing
we've ever done
i used to be the 3d guy i was the clint
or the wren of the group
but as times changed sold my role in the
company and my 3d skills have since
disappeared perhaps so sitting down with
this piece not only was it about
making a tribute there's also a chance
for me to sit down and be like all right
just an old dog but i got any new tricks
first thing i start with is block
everything out to make sure
that i have all the pieces in place once
i get all my pieces laid out then i'm
able to frame it up
and see what looks aesthetically the
best from here i'll just start
populating the scene with assets and
replacing the blockout with
higher quality mega scans assets you
always go to megascans at some point in
your process
because they just have tons of photo
real elements that you can slap into
your scene and it just works
the environment was the most fun part of
this i downloaded some textures of
heavy metal machines and i slapped those
onto some cubes
uh this is copying ian hubert's style
thanks ian
but yeah you basically slap an image
texture onto a cube take that part and
you extrude it out and then there's
another part of the image texture
that's like a circle so you're like oh
i'll cut out a circle and extrude it out
and basically you just let the image
texture dictate how you model this
object and so you end up with something
that looks like it could actually be a
factory machine or something like that
because it's pulling from image
references and it's kind of a natural
way to model
industrial things so i actually went
back to where we originally shot this
it's under the highway like one street
over
and i basically use this app on my phone
called polycam
by pointing at stuff it starts scanning
it it's using the lidar sensor of the
phone
you've seen peter talk about it before
it's actually pretty amazing using the
scanner you're getting two things you're
getting the geometry of the actual like
pillars but you're also getting that
grungy texture that comes with it
including
the very real uh spray painting graffiti
that's on the wall
i've been playing around with this
program called
mine ways which basically can take
minecraft worlds and
convert them into 3d models i'm going to
be using them for some stuff in unreal
to basically create maps to have scenes
take place in for future videos
but in that process i discovered it's
really fun to take some of this stuff
and render it out real nice in octane so
that's the core idea here
i have this huge map this huge world you
actually look at how much stuff is in
here it's pretty
nuts there's a lot of stuff going on in
here i found this really great pack
of mountain displacement textures which
are basically just black and white
pictures
they look like noise maps but when you
apply this and you raise something up if
it's white or lower something down
it's black you end up with mountains and
it actually looks really really good
so once i did this and i picked my
little spot where the robot would be
well i'd drop the robot in i'm actually
in business here
the thing is i need to do motion capture
so
fired up the suit sam recorded it for me
i imported the fbx file from
xsense there it is that was pretty dang
cool
so we also had the dog which was rigged
up with inverse kinematics from clint
inverse kinematics are really neat
basically rather than having to rotate
this part and this part
and this part you can just move this
part and everything else will
follow accordingly for myself i was a
photo scan
cliff came over and he photo scanned me
a bunch of pictures of me
basically naked in my backyard from here
i'm gonna export this out to mixamo
auto rig it with mixamo choose some
awesome mocap data for me to be doing
bring that back into c4d and then i'm
animated in my scene
i actually got sam and nico in costume
and i said please let me 3d scan you
which i did and then i took those 3d
scans i brought them into blender
and i made some alterations to make them
fit the original piece mike was a
different story i texted mike asking him
if he could scan his head and send it to
me which he did thank you mike
and i then took that and i just forced
it on to sam's body
as i've said many times before it's so
far away
that you're not gonna notice which is
like the most important
phrase you'll ever learn as a vfx artist
so my original plan for the sam and nico
film them on a green screen with the
camera and just have them standing
waving back and forth and i was like
sweet but then when i went to drop them
into the shot
it wasn't really working very well
because their feet don't line up so i
was like
i have to call i have to call the clone
hey peter is this
sorry i don't have this number saved
it's only your maker
mom i had a question for you though
what was the name of that 2d to 3d
software use it's like from facebook
oh yeah it's a sweet research paper from
facebook called
python and yeah it uses ai to take your
2d photo and turn it into a 3d model of
a person it's pretty sweet
and it's also free and accessible to
everybody okay thanks peter
wait sorry who is this so basically
using pi foot it generated
these 3d models but it doesn't generate
the textures so peter actually
additionally went above and beyond
and reprojected these textures onto
those models
as you can see if i rotate to the back
side of sam here you look
the projection of the texture is
duplicated on their backs there's no
texture for the back of the model
so it just kind of gets duplicated in
the back you look at miko
for the weapons we have the original
dubstep gun in here which i grabbed it
was just laying in a bucket downstairs i
took it out and i put it on a c-stand
and i
got a quick 3d scan of it and we're good
to go slap it in there it's ready it's
done in the original video they used an
after effects plug-in called trap code
form
the lasers aren't adding any light to
the scene around them as they would if
lasers were real and so in this i wanted
to have the lasers be a 3d
object casting light onto the scene so
you can take this dimly lit scene and
fill it up with
beautiful blue green and red lasers the
lasers lighting up the scene definitely
helped and if dubstep guns 2 gets
greenlit on corridordigital.com
i will definitely be using this
technique and the vfx for that video so
head on over to corridordigital.com to
greenlight that
so there's two things that are being
animated there's the axe and then
there's the steak stem the axe is very
straightforward very simple
all i'm doing is pivoting the axe on the
center point and
i'm going into my keyframes and making
sure that the keyframes look really nice
as far as the stakes go what i'm doing
is using
this emitter and the emitter has
instances of the stake model
in them and i'm making this little shoot
that you don't see
it's kind of like a trough and that's
going to keep the stakes
in place on this slide so for animating
the basketball i actually thought about
going through and doing animation curves
and getting it all set precisely but i
was like you know what what if i just
try to shoot some hoops
digitally so i set a rigid body
simulation
on the basketball i gave it some initial
velocity and spin
and gave it a position and i got it so
it bounces off the backboard and goes
into the net and falls in
it's pretty aesthetically pleasing if i
don't say so myself to bring this all
together and make it feel alive
i needed to actually have some plants
some foliage so i found this plug-in
for cinema 4d called forester it has
really nice trees
like really good-looking trees they blow
in the wind
just right and the leaves flutter just
right i'm not just gonna stop at trees
we got flowers and once you combine the
grass and the flowers and the textures
and the logs and the trees
suddenly got yourselves a landscape so
remember every portal you're looking
through you have to see something on the
other side which means i have
five portals to put something behind
i took some images from google street
view for like the two blue portals on
the ground
up on the left actually that's a whole
separate render it's the same scene i
just made a new camera
that's looking down from underneath the
basketball hoop and of course
the portal in the middle i wanted to
have the whole scene shrunken down
in there i couldn't just drop the same
image
into that i needed to render out a
slightly further back
slightly down perspective of the same
shot so if you look carefully
it's a whole different render there in
the center and then i just did that
several more times
i was actually able to finish this whole
render in about two and a half
days three days tops whereas the
original shot took me
a full week just to do the stakes coming
down the slides i
am very happy with how this turned out
and i'm excited to show everybody i
can't wait to show the guys
i i want to see what they do too
today we're watching all the sweet
10-year renders that all of us did took
us 10 years to make these
well ten years to get to this point to
be able to make these yeah so these
surrenders were technically 10 years in
the making
we are joined by griffin and jordan it's
griffin's birthday and i would love to
satisfy him
[Laughter]
never gets old all right everybody it's
time to present
the work that we've been working so hard
upon so i put a lot of effort into this
unfortunately due to time constraints i
was working on this falcon video
the the render settings were pretty bad
those are sausages to meatballs good
good job
i tried really you got the transition
you got the balls fading through the
floor
it does technically loop so i did manage
to find a little bit of time this
morning
so i just whip this together pretty
quickly
[Music]
the way the light mount the edge light
on niko's legs and
sam's calves you got the freaking
basketball hoop in the orange render to
the left
this is all possible just due to modern
tech that's this wasn't possible like 10
years ago
and trick shots yeah exactly that's
crazy but it's got the same vibe
i love thank you i'm pretty pleased with
it
all right so dumpster guns came out 10
years ago this summer and
i was man i was 11. no i was 13 when
dubstep guns came out tell me that
it was so inspiring when i saw it the
first time and so i wanted to
do that as my art piece to kind of pay
homage
to it
you're the sweetest holy [ __ ]
oh sweet i love those particle effects
right yeah the lighting fits really
nicely off of it especially when it goes
when it goes green from sam's blast
can you see the rubble in the foreground
the color palette this is so nice
it's not just orange it's not just warm
tones it's like
it's got the violets and the magentas
and the blue and like
i i find myself just like constantly
waiting for that to happen again and
when he coat he like rears
up i'm like oh here we go is that my
favorite part of the loop is
they're going down super cool that's
super sweet let's go
[Applause]
clancy jones if this doesn't impress me
where you can't be friends
oh my god
dude your animation is so good you
rebuilt the whole environment
yeah the whole thing dude this just
looks photo real this is so
detailed it looks like it's a photo on
the left there yeah my baby's a fire
like it's so therapeutic i guess that's
satisfying
[Applause]
all right we got a 10-year render 10
years
that environment
is minecraft i've never played minecraft
but is it this tranquil and
like majestic minecraft is one of the
most approachable games
i mean yeah i want to just like dive
into this
through the old camera that you have
right beside you also the old hvac
there's an hvx in there it's like a
little
little nod you know one of the first
cameras we used
[Applause]
i'm legitimately a little nervous solid
yeah that's for me
it's all about that steam
[Music]
whoa
dude it's very painterly it is holy crap
i've definitely got some horizon zero
dawn vibes from this
the whole post-apocalyptic thing i love
how
you even timed up the scratch so it's
like he loses the tension there for the
stick he's like oh i'm itchy
the lighting with your foliage
is killing really does feel like a
painting that has come to life
when it comes to art especially like
traditional art where you're painting or
drawing
once you're finished you put your
signature on the piece and every artist
has their way of doing a signature
i was nervous starting this render
because dubstep guns is very
important to me and i wanted to do it
justice i didn't want to
have a lackluster render commemorating
10 years of this video
i'm happy with myself i was able to
recreate that stake shot i think in two
years
i've made some progress i honestly think
this is one of the best renders i've
ever made
what's funny about this is that when we
shot the original video i had
very very little 3d experience so
everything you see in the original
portal trick shots video is done just
using after effects
but now a hundred percent of this was
made in 3d space and
rendered it's been cool it's been really
liberating to like
make a really robust piece of digital
art and it's really nice
to actually have this work and to know
that i can still make it happen
i think this piece does a really good
job of kind of putting bookmarks
on two ends of this period of time
everything from when we started to the
present we never thought
this would be something that would carry
us this far into the future
it was like a all right well here's the
thing we're doing this is fun but
hey we're trying to make movies or tv
shows or things like that it's like
turns out what you're watching right now
this video
this is the career that has cemented
and created a foundation for all of our
lives anyone who's a fan of the channel
here
would instantly see like wow like i
remember
that other version of that sam that's
not sam now this is like this other
version of him
and that's all summed up in a janky
photo scan done with the connect from
2014.
so i'm happy to announce that we're
going to be doing our first corridor nft
drop that's right you can own the very
first viral video that we've made on the
corridor channel
minecraft the last minecart plus these
five renders they'll be for sale on
maker's place
starting right now there's an auction
now i know a fair amount of you are
critical of nfts in particular their
impact on the environment is something
that does need to be addressed which we
are going to address we're going to take
the amount of carbon that is created by
an nft we're gonna multiply that by
a hundred and we're going to offset that
i'll link to the description below to
the website that we're using for our
calculation
so if you're a collector and you would
like to own a little bit of corridor
history head on over to maker's place
the auction is starting
right now thank you for watching
everybody we'll see you in the next
video